qu'est ce que vous allez je vous sauver
j'ai une fille de 18 ans et ce matin
elle a eu un accident très prêt à porter
charge aux urgences vraiment désolé
quand j'étais adolescente j'ai failli me
noyer alors vous avez quitté votre ça
m'est arrivé plusieurs fois c'est pour
ça que j'ai demandé à ce cas de
m'étrangler il faut que j'ai
l'impression de me noyer
maman oui tu encore à la
ça fait tellement
j'ai cru d'abord perdu tu es tout ce que
j'ai
ma petite fille elle avait cinq en cinq
ans c'est la fumée qui ne suivent pas
les flammes on devrait lui demander de
rester
en charbon vous vous êtes milliers de
quelque chose qui ne vous regarde pas
maintenant vous ne reconnaissez pas
votre fille chaque esprit fini par
quitter son corps un jour ou l'autre
tu me manques amy jo comment tu connais
mon nom de famille
il me dit je sais
tu te défendre ils nous accusent tu veux
susciter des femmes etc belli on parle
de ma fille billets mode saas est marié
il faut que tu m'aides à la faire re
arrêter ça
tu peux pas lui faire de mal si tu
savais tout ce que je peux faire
personne ne va abattre ce pauvre con
sauf moi